viva las vegas the sponsor of this next
segment is back at the orleans this
weekend of rockabilly jc fernandez is
live with more how you doing out there
jc
hey guys awesome it's the weather like
sally said it's fantastic out here the
weather's perfect i've got tom he's the
man behind viva las vegas how would you
describe the rockabilly vibe
the welcoming vibe is about everything
to do with the 50s the music the culture
the clothes the cars everything and
that's what this weekend is all about
it's an international affair i met some
people that flew in here from london to
attend this weekend now today tomorrow
and saturday the car show is taking
place look at this car right here and
look how low this is insane look how low
this car is to the ground how does this
car even clear the parking lot this is
just one of the many vehicles you'll see
out here this weekend and and tom what
are some as far as when it comes to
judging the car what are some of the
things that the judges look for this
weekend there's different categories
like best hot rod best best custom the
furthest driven
um
then the one that i choose
is the tom ingram choice there's the tom
ingram category where tom just walks
through and picks his favorite car they
get an award and what do you look at
when you're picking a winning car this
weekend the car that i'd most like to be
going home in tonight
the car he wants to drive back to l.a so
we got the car show and saturday is the
uh the grand daddy the big daddy
what's taking place on saturday saturday
there's a car show and then we've got
the live bands on the stage we've got
tons of vendors the wedding chapel
there's a lot going on and there's pool
parties throughout the weekend yes and
there's burlesque shows or contests
what's going on and there's here she's
got the rockabilly vibe you're looking
great looks fantastic what's taking
place as far as clothing this weekend
most a lot of people are going to be in
50 style clothing but there's also a lot
of modern interpretation of 50s style
clothing now if i were to do jc's chores
lance i need to spin all the way back
around look at the riviera this with it
right here this car this car wins jc's
choice for the weekend look at this
stunning black and white gorgeous
interior this would if you had a jc's
choice i'd pick this one okay now do you
ever do you have so far the cars that
are out here yeah tom's choice my
favorite is actually just over here
let's go right here
it's red and white one over here the
buick electric convertible
i gotta wrap it up here in a second but
this is man gorgeous that's one of my
favorites saturday uh what time does the
first band take the stage about midday
12 midday beautiful beautiful car show
happening today tomorrow and the big
festivities take place on saturday i
like this one tom thank you so much viva
las vegas here at the orleans come out
and join us i'll send it back to you
guys in the studio
he he was really working for that jc's
choice he's like tom can i can i just
get it i think he was trying to lead to
it like tom just let him have it
otherwise jc is not going to sleep
tonight it's going to be
so much fun i choose jc's choice too
it was a nice car i could see you in one
of those yeah old-fashioned cars yeah
cool i like it i like it all right with
their youtube videos racking in hundreds
of millions of viewers viewings croatian
cellist duo two cellos have taken the
classical world by storm and i wonder if
that's like a oh to two chains
oh i'll i'll tell you later
that no you don't have to exp i'm not
okay you don't have to explain every
modern reference to me
it's okay to assume that maybe i've
heard of two chains okay
okay okay
that's why you just said to chain but
okay
moving on
you just finished this